would you rather bang a bunch of models  but nobody knows or not actually [ __ ]  them but have everyone think you did i  think i'd rather the second part because  i kind of lived that as it is you know  there's like four porn stars that the  internet thinks i had sex with yeah and  so and then people are like did they  [ __ ] and i'm like i have to dispel it  because it gets a little too much and  i'm like we're just friends  you know but it's kind of fun for them  to be like you nailed that one like they  think i did it that's great that's great  there's there's one but there that's  great i like that that that but if  nobody knows like there is one and i  want people to know but i can't ever say  she would get so mad and i'll never do  it again